in London British authorities are being
asked some tough questions this morning
as they piece together the chain of
events that led to two people being
killed and three others injured in a
terror attack near London Bridge on
Friday the suspect was a convicted
terrorist he had been deemed a threat to
the public in the past he was shot and
killed by police the attack was in the
same place of another terror incident
two years ago Holly Williams has the
latest from London this morning Holly
good morning good morning well the
attacker was named this morning as Osman
Khan a convicted terrorist who was
jailed in 2012 for plotting to blow up
the London Stock Exchange he was
released early and he was on probation
the British media is reporting he'd
agreed to wear an electronic monitor he
was apparently a lone attacker armed
with a knife and a determination to kill
in this exclusive video from the Daily
Mail bystanders are seen fighting him
back with fire extinguishers they
tackled him to the ground
an act of breathtaking heroism according
to London's mayor a plainclothes police
officer removed his weapon and the
police shot him at close range he was
wearing what the police are calling a
hoax suicide vest Thomas grey says he
was one of those who stepped in he was
you know wielding two knives one was
sort of duct-taped to his hand so all I
could do what what after the guys had
sort of held him down and was sort of
pinning into the ground you know kind of
trying to stamp his how did I put on his
restaurant you know release the knife
Richard Walton is the former head of
counterterrorism for the London Police
in the last 18 months to two years
they've been 22 disrupted terrorist
plots in the UK that's a high number of
attacks plots that have been disrupted
and this is the first attack in the UK
since 2017 but the terrible irony is
that Khan reportedly set off on his
stabbing spree while attending a
conference on rehabilitating prisoners
many here are asking why he was released
from jail early
including the British prime minister I
have long argued that it is a mistake to
allow serious and violent criminals to
come out of prison early a house outside
of London was searched overnight in
connection with this attack Dana Polly
thank you very much